you want to talk about VHS tapes let me
show you something just can't throw them
away so many memories VHS is a new found
footage style horror movie and I bet you
that right there I have lost you
entirely I've lost it you're gone you
have no interest in this movie you know
what I don't blame you because I felt
the same way my friends are telling
about this movie and they were saying
you know what Chris it looks dumb I know
it's another found footage movie
chernobyl Diaries was just terrible some
of these people I knew who saw they were
like this movie is actually scary it's
actually well done and my reaction to
everyone saying this kind of stuff was
basically always the same basically Tom
Hardy from lawless if you've seen the
movie yet I just had no interest at all
because I am done with found-footage
horror movies that are stupid and I'm
just done but you guys know me I try to
watch everything and I try to do it for
you guys at the same time and to my
surprise this is the scariest movie I've
seen all year by far this movie
disturbed me it bothered me and last
night when I went to bed I was looking
in my closet I'm not kidding
I was looking at my closet and I kind of
moved the door to the side so it wasn't
all open for me to see as I laid there
in bed that's how much this movie got
under my skin
the movie is essentially five short
films all rolled into one it starts out
with these guys they're searching this
house they're looking for a very
specific tape as they're searching for
the specific tape they put them into the
VCR and watch them to see which one is
the one that they're apparently looking
for then we see what they're watching
and what we get is the strangest tape
collection had some old creepy guy who
lives alone could possibly own and
naturally when you have a film that is
basically a collection of short stories
some will be better than others to in
particular stand out greatly the first
and the last the first one is this party
that these guys are having and there's a
very creepy girl there who keeps
watching them that's all I'm gonna say
the second one is a second honeymoon
that a couples going on for like in the
the mountains or whatever in their
hiking and another strange girl is
watching the know this second one that
was the one that I felt was the weakest
let me get this college trip where these
guys are going to this lake and there's
these two hot chicks there of course
that must disrobe or Tropes cliches
abound during this one trust me and then
there's this strange like virtual did
little killer that's like infecting
their camera or something it's it's
pretty creepy the fourth one is this
Skype conversation between the girl and
a guy and she thinks that her apartment
is haunted in some way because she keeps
hearing things and we get to see them
have this conversation while they try to
search the apartment to figure out what
this is the last one is a Halloween
party in which the people who are going
to a party choose the wrong house and
they find some incredibly creepy stuff
in there now all the while there's
another story going on in the house
where the guys who are actually watching
these VHS tapes are and there's
something in that house that is scary as
well and as these guys take out the
tapes you can look like in the room
where they last were stuff has changed
and moved since the last time they put
in the last tape and you're like that
wasn't there before
that used to be there why isn't it there
now where is it hmm two things happen to
me during this movie and I'm incredibly
ashamed to admit them but I will to you
guys because you guys are awesome and
I'm gonna tell you what I did number one
I actually looked away I looked away at
a part of this movie I have never done
that ever during a scary movie the the
sad thing is nothing actually happened I
was just anticipating something about to
happen I felt like such a little girl it
was so annoying I've never done that
before
and number two this is the big one all
right now this I I can't it I'm so
afraid to admit that I did this but it's
true I i watch horror movies all the
time I am well versed in horror movies
I've seen a ton of found-footage movies
most of them are not good some of them
are if it's not used as a gimmick it
works as a plus this movie it worked as
a plus and during the Skype conversation
short film I won't say what happened but
there was a part in the movie where this
happened to me
well I'm gonna go kill myself I gasped
and brought my hands to my mouth like a
little girl
good job BHS you scared me now yes this
movie is scary and suspenseful and
freaky and terrifying at times but there
is something about it that just is off
and I'll tell you what it is the movie
does not make sense and it's not meant
to but that will really irritate some
viewers like if you watch this movie and
you hate it I'll completely understand
like I would totally understand if you
hated this movie it's not the kind of
movie that you watch and you make sense
of it there are so many things that
happen and you just kind of have to buy
it the found footage style of it makes
it seem so realistic to the point where
it's just like okay I guess some things
just aren't explained and you know what
that's what scares me the most the stuff
that isn't explained that's left open to
interpretation in horror movies where
you're like what in the world was like
what it's like that line in Batman
Begins and you always fear what you
don't understand it's exactly like that
it's so weird at times and so difficult
to figure out actually what happened in
some of these short stories that it
starts to be even more disturbing and
that's what happened to me I can
understand someone who wants more
explanations being like earth for me
though I enjoyed this movie has a lot of
the horror tropes and cliches though
random women must disrobe at all times
and one thing that did bother me is the
whole film is trying to portray this
very realistic tone but at certain times
where they needed a jump scare they did
insert music in the movie and I noticed
that and I was like that doesn't seem to
fit with the tone that you were creating
before of this very realistic no music
thing I honestly don't know if I can
watch that first one with that girl
again without kind of like going like
that like I don't know man got under my
skin in it it really had chilled me man
it chilled me to the bone I'm gonna give
VHS a B+ it's the best horror movie I've
seen so far this year in regards to
scaring me cabin in the woods is still
the best horror movie I've seen this
year so did you see the movie did you
hate it and you loved it I understand if
you hate it it's perfectly fine honestly
but I bet you at least one part of it
kind of got under your skin a little bit
thanks for watching guys and as always
if you liked this review then you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]